breaking aids le idee dirompenti sia le
idee esplosive idee che possono cambiare
il corso della storia
che si tratti di innovazioni
tecnologiche di scoperte scientifiche o
di produzioni di arti fatti culturali
la domanda è da dove vengono le breaking
news dove si trovano e come si fa ad
averne la risposta nessuno lo sa
quello della produzione delle idee è un
territorio estremamente
affascinante ma ancora totalmente
misterioso
nelle parole del filosofo terence
mckenna l'atto creativo consiste nel
gettare le reti dell'immaginazione umana
nell'oceano del caos sul quale siamo
sospesi nel tentativo di pescare delle
idee
ebbene a partire da questa la metafora
ittica di matrice è chiaramente
neoplatonica vorrei provare a distillare
alcune possibili linee guida su come
fare per pescare per andare a pesca di
breaking elias è bene tanto per
cominciare pare che per pescare delle
breaking ai ds faccia bene dormire così
a dormire bene dormire anche a lungo o
fare dei pisolini quella ci sono
innumerevoli storie di idee
apparse in sogno quasi più o meno
compiute tra le varie storie una delle
mie preferite e quella del poeta inglese
samuel taylor coleridge il quale
ricevette in sogno pressoché compiuta la
famosa poesia kublai khan
dopodiché si svegliò inizio a
trascrivere questa poesia ma
sfortunatamente qualcuno bussa alla sua
porta
proprio mentre stava per trascrivere il
finale della poesia e il finale la
poesia è andato per cui le breaking dias
possono essere estremamente
volatili oltre che molto capricciose
insomma sta di fatto che dormire dormire
bene è sicuramente una buona e un buon
suggerimento ma nell'oceano così
paradossale dell'ebri king ideas valle è
vero anche esattamente il contrario
questo signore era paul erdos un famoso
matematico estremamente prolifico in
tutta la sua vita ebbene erdos dormì
pochissime ore per notte probabilmente
aiutato dalle ingenti dosi di caffeina
che ingeriva quotidianamente tanto che
alla fine della sua vita arrivo a dire
che un matematico e una macchina per
trasformare caffeina in teoremi e
sicuramente non mancano nella storia
delle idee riferimenti ad altre sostanze
psicotrope utilizzate dagli uomini come
esca per andare a pesca di breaking aids
non solo nei campi appunto non sono
utilizzate da artisti bohemien o da
musicisti rock o ip per esempio questo
signore è kary mullis questo simpatico
surfista grimaldi e vinse nel 1983 vinse
il premio nobel per la chimica per una
famosa breaking ivy as completamente
rivoluzionaria chiamata polimerasis
chain reaction è bene che rimanesse
nella sua biografia e dichiara di aver
avuto l'intuizione di questa scoperta
assolutamente groundbreaking grazie
all'utilizzo di acido lisergico e
appunto ci sono altri famosi premi nobel
che hanno dichiarato la loro affezione
per questa sostanza psicotropa tre tra i
quali francis crick all altro famoso
premio nobel per la fisica a richard
feynman insomma quando si vince un
premio nobel si può dichiarare con molto
candore anche di aver fatto uso di
sostanze psicotrope illegali
ebbene un altro modo per predisporsi ad
avere delle breaking aids è quello di
esplorare e di coltivare la cosiddetta
serendipità e cioè serendipità significa
scoprire qualcosa dal mentre si sta
cercando qualcosa di completamente
diverso e come successe a cristoforo
colombo cercandole in navigando appunto
alla ricerca delle indie e invece trovò
come tutti sappiamo l'america o un'altra
famosa scoperta di natura serendipità fu
la scoperta della dinamite e da parte di
alfred nobel il quale appunto istituì
l'omonimo premio
grazie appunto al ingenti proventi della
vendita della dinamite ad oggi sappiamo
tutti che il premio nobel è uno dei
riconoscimenti più prestigiosi al mondo
per le breaking ai ds letteralmente
esplosiva
e infine un altro dei degli argomenti a
me molto cari quando si parla di
concepire delle breaking ei ds a che
fare con l'idea di ars combinatoria e
cioè nel mondo delle idee le idee bene
farle collider le
contaminare remixare come dice qualcuno
perché da queste connessioni non obi e
possono emergere appunto delle breaking
ai ds un esempio tra tanti e la scoperta
o meglio l'invenzione della stampa di
gutenberg il signor gutenberg riadattò
una pressa da vino per un oggetto
appunto molto noto da molti anni per lo
riconvertì per l'invenzione appunto
della stampa che è stata una breaking
aidia anzi una meta breaking elias e
vogliamo perché da allora in poi la
diffusione delle idee ha avuto
sicuramente un impennata
un ultima idea con la quale volevo
chiudere questa carrellata è che quando
si parla di breaking ei ds le breaking
news e sono sempre un processo
collettivo
anziché un processo singolo individuale
e cioè sebbene chi concepisce una
breaking ha idea in qualche modo prende
il merito della concezione stessa
le breaking ideas nascono sempre in un
contesto
intellettuale culturale e anche
ambientale che permette appunto
l'emergere di breaking ai ds per cui
quando si tratta di concepire delle idee
nuove siamo tutti in un certo senso dei
nani sulle spalle di giganti
ma facendo questa carrellata di breaking
aids che provo sempre un grande senso di
ammirazione di riverenza nei confronti
delle di questi giganti del pensiero e
della creatività umana quindi tutte
queste idee possono essere ovviamente
motivo di ispirazione motivo di stimolo
ma al contempo possono creare una sorta
di di separazione possono farci vedere
questi personaggi come molto lontani da
noi proprio perché sappiamo che qui oggi
probabilmente
non sarà alto il tasso di premi nobel
vinti in questa sala sebbene appunto il
mio augurio per tutti voi e rimane
valido ma allora come possiamo fare come
può una persona di statura più ordinarie
come me a relazionarsi alle breaking
aires a questo punto vorrei proporvi una
distinzione e la distinzione è la
seguente waiting irish con la b
maiuscola e breaking ai dias con la p
minuscola e celebri king e riesco la b
maiuscola sono quelle idee
dirompenti che apro che cambiano in modo
permanente un campo di indagine
quindi le briefing e riesco la b
maiuscola possono cambiare un paradigma
possono rivoluzionare o addirittura
aprile un nuovo campo di di esplorazione
come per esempio il telescopio o le
leggi della gravitazione universale all
inconscio o i big floyd cose di questo
tipo
invece le breaking e riescono la b
minuscola sono quelle idee delle
breaking elias più del quotidiano che
ognuno di noi può concepire senza
intento senza intenzione di diventare
famosi o di appunto di vincere dei premi
quindi qualche modo le bering aids sono
una celebrazione al processo creativo
individuale soggettivo personale nella
vita quotidiana per il puro piacere
appunto per puro piacere stesso che
nasce dal processo creativo quindi
diciamo che concepire e lavorare sulle
breaking ideas del quotidiano è una cosa
assolutamente alla portata di tutti
oltre che assolutamente auspicabile per
raggiungere ricchezza significato e in
ultima analisi aumentare la qualità
della vita di ognuno di noi a questo
punto vorrei rivelarvi un segreto su
come fare per aumentare la frequenza di
breaking aidia se nella vostra vita
quotidiana
ebbene il singolo è più importante
ingrediente per aumentare le breaking
aids nella vita quotidiana è coltivare
il senso della meraviglia
mai per essere un'idea abbastanza
acquisita abbastanza condivisa quella
secondo la quale
coltivare il senso di meraviglia il
senso di stupore nei confronti della
realtà è il singolo è più importante
motore propulsore o catalizzatore per il
processo creativo stesso
generalmente con il tempo che passa
il senso di meraviglia una persona
normale perde questo sguardo di stupore
e di meraviglia tipicamente infantile ma
la capacità di riuscire a mantenerlo e
coltivarlo e l'ingrediente ristic a
principale degli individui altamente
creativi anche verso la fine della loro
vita come si può fare a muoverci in
questa direzione
prendo due consigli presi da mialich inc
senti mi hai una delle maggiori autorità
in campo di breaking ei ds tratto da
questo famoso libro chiamato creativity
ebbene secondo cinzia di meena lee
bastano due rapidi e semplici consigli
che ognuno di noi può mettere in pratica
nella propria vita il primo è quello di
sorprendersi ed essere meravigliati da
qualcosa ogni giorno per quanto possa
sembrare semplice e lineare questo
concetto la vita quotidiana offre
molteplici occasioni per meravigliarsi
ad essere stupiti quindi la capacità di
preservare quest'occhio questo sguardo
sul mondo che ci circonda è sicuramente
una caratteristica nobile che può essere
ovviamente allenata il secondo
ingrediente che fa da contrappunto il
primo è sorprendere una persona ogni
giorno quindi prenderlo come esercizio
quello di inventarsi dei modi per
sorprendersi per sorprendere chi ci sta
vicino che sia un amico un parente un
collega e il secondo consiglio molto
pragmatico per tenere desto è vivo e
attivo questo senso di meraviglia nella
propria vita
ebbene in questo quadro si inserisce si
innesta anche il mio personale lavoro di
magic experience designer e cioè il mio
lavoro consiste nel creare dei contesti
dei momenti nei quali si possa appunto
attivare la curiosità e il mio lavoro
consiste nel distribuire dispensare
delle dosi di meraviglia alle persone
con le quali interagisco eppure questo è
appunto la natura del mio lavoro e di
recente io il mio partner creativo
mariano tomatis abbiamo deciso di
rilasciare il cosiddetto codice sorgente
come ci piace chiamarlo di questa di
questa disciplina della nostra breaking
aids che chiamiamo magic experience
design in questo libro ho chiamato
l'arte di stupire nel quale è una
collezione a disposizione di chiunque
voglia coltivare il senso di meraviglia
nella propria vita e voglia creare dei
momenti di stupore per chi gli sta
vicino
quindi in ultima analisi possiamo
riassumere la ricetta per avere delle
breaking ideas e molto semplice e cioè
dormite bene assumere le giuste vitamine
e mantenete un lo sguardo di stupore e
di meraviglia nei confronti del mondo
per concludere vorrei a questo punto
mostrarvi
un ultima idea vorrei condividere con
voi quest'ultima idea
bene questa come tutti riconoscerete e
una lampadina
uno dei simboli più iconici e più noti
di breaking aids e al contempo una
breaking ideas in se stessa che ha
richiesto lunghe una lunga preparazione
molti prototipi
molti errori e tentativi prima di
trovare la sua forma definitiva compiuta
e funzionante per cui il mio augurio
finale per tutti voi per
riuscire a concepire delle breaking
eight years è più o meno questo
in effetti piccolo rituale
apotropaico per concepire dell'ebri king
ai ds
e riuscire a
perseverare
e non perdere la pazienza perché le idee
non sono non arrivano mai compiutamente
nella loro forma definitiva ma appunto
sono frutto di un processo e quindi in
ultima analisi ci vuole appunto
perseveranza e pazienza e soprattutto
anche una gran bella dose di fortuna